welcome back to our short series on
using GC api's this video is intended
for anyone interested in preparing for
their future careers and in this episode
I will walk you through how to integrate
in web-based ordering system with a
Google sheet
note that this video's description
contains a wonderful code lab with this
exact use case created by my peer eric
koleda along with other helpful links
so to start imagine you work for a bike
sharing startup that has a bike ordering
web app built on nodejs
if you're familiar with javascript
nodejs is great since it runs on
javascript code outside of a browser to
develop things like web servers the key
functionality of this app is keeping
track of changes in inventory unit price
and the status of each bike order the
goal now is to have this information
synced with a Google sheet along with
real-time pivot tables and charts for
easy visualization in order to track the
sheets created by the app and keep the
data synced to the sheets we generate a
table in our database to make this
possible we use a library called sequel
eyes which helps map and synchronize
data entries to objects within databases
such as my sequel Postgres etc a node
you can containerize code into it is
called modules and then import them
using require as well as module export
for other files to access next we need
to fetch all of the spreadsheets we've
stored when the index page loads so we
can display them in a list and with a
bit of HTML we will create two buttons
one called create to generate
spreadsheets and another button called
sync to sync that data we then move on
to downloading the Google API s no js'
client library and the oauth2 library
with these you can create an access
token to get credentials and initializes
the sheets API client next we'll use the
spreadsheets dot create method for
creating the spreadsheet the
spreadsheets dot batch update method is
commonly used for nearly every type of
manipulation to a spreadsheet because it
takes an array of request objects as an
put which contains specific operations
to perform in this example we map the
columns headers to fields in the
databases order object finally we create
a function which converts the order
objects into cells and adds data
validation for the different data types
for example the column status displays a
drop-down with values such as pending
shipped and delivered and there you go
we now have our application exporting to
Google sheets now I'm waiting for
someone to ask couldn't we have achieved
a similar result exporting the data as
CSV s and converting them into Google
sheets manually well I'm glad you asked
since the additional benefit in using
this API based approach is that on top
of managing sign-ins and automatic
syncing it also has the ability to add
complex features to spreadsheets such as
pivot tables and charts automatically
let me show you this in this final piece
note that as a best practice is to have
two different sheets created within a
spreadsheet one for the raw data and the
second to display the charts this allows
for the code use for syncing to focus on
the data exclusively and not on the
visualizations so let's return to our
earlier create spreadsheet method and
add the following properties for
creating a pivot table we will also need
to capture the ID of that second sheet
to build the following three requests
which build the pivot table format the
pivot table and create a chart let's
take a quick look at each so this is
what the build pivot table request looks
like which describes the columns and
values that should be summarized then
there's the build form pivot table
request which ensures that data is
formatted in a currency and the last one
is the build add chart request which
creates a bar chart called revenue per
product and there we have it a lovely
synchronous process between a database
and those realizations in Google
Spreadsheets
my name is AGV and this has been a brief
introduction to G Suites developer tools
chairs
[Music]
you